If you died a horrible death
and came back to life, what would you do?
You've returned from beyond the grave
and will be forced to hunt horrifying aliens
and countless death games.
And you can't escape.
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made, what you should do
and how to beat the death games in Gantz.
This kid here has no idea
that he is about to die.
Kei, over here is just another
Japanese youngster
hoping to find a job when down the subway
he notices someone familiar in the distance
in between the crowds Kei notices
this kid, Kato, an old school friend
he hasn't seen in years, and he and Kato
wait for the incoming train.
Little do they both know that this train
will be the death of both of them.
Suddenly, someone near Kato collapses
onto the train tracks and goody two shoes.
Kato rushes down
like a knight in shining armor to save him.
But he can't get up and the train is coming.
Kei looks on in sheer awkwardness
as he tries to avoid being spotted.
But tough shit because Kato then spots
Kei prompting an awkward, staring contest
for a few seconds as he watches
Kato save this man from certain death.
But then the roaring engine of Japan's metro
comes charging down the tracks, and Kato
can't get up so Kei quickly.
Goes to help poor Kato, but in the process
gets dragged down by accident
onto the tracks until both of their lips
meet to kiss the train dead.
Okay. This was a brutal mistake.
These kids waited around for too long,
and that's what got them killed.
Considering
that they're standing on train tracks,
they should be actively trying to escape
as soon as possible
instead of sitting around
and talking about what to do.
Their very first mistake was not realizing
that there's an emergency compartment
hidden under the tracks
of every train station in the city of Tokyo.
Even if they were unable to climb
because of how difficult it is to get up,
we can clearly see that there's a small gap
that two people could fit in
right to the side of them.
Look, it's understandable
that they might be freaking the hell out
because of this high speed train
coming towards them.
But let's stay calm, folks.
We need to stay alive.
Tokyo has a high rate of train
related deaths in the past few decades.
Because of this, safety measures
have been enhanced
by the Metropolitan authorities
to make sure these incidents
become a few and far between thing.
However, there is another way
that we could escape this situation
relatively unscathed if we're willing
to sacrifice our new old friend here.
Since he brought me into this situation,
I would quickly try to convince him
to let me use him as a human trampoline
to push me up into the air
and over the train ledge.
Now, whether or not
our friend here is going to survive
is a tricky question, but
that's not our problem anymore now, is it?
Kei and Kato suddenly
wake up to find themselves in a barren
room washed over by the white lights
of this seemingly nefarious apartment.
And they're not alone.
And in front of them
sits other confused and terrified individuals
who also don't know how they got there.
The two boys
then turn around to find an unknown
black sphere in the middle of the room.
They then investigate the rest of the
apartment to find themselves trapped inside.
With all the doors and windows locked.
Kei and Kato
try and piece the puzzle together,
and they realize that they aren't
the only ones
who seemingly just died
because everyone else in this room
came here after suddenly dying in random ways
and no one knows anything.
Just then, this black sphere interrupts
everyone by emitting
what appears to be the body of a young girl
as she seemingly fizzles into existence
out of thin air
and she plops right on to case left,
freaking him the hell out
and not in a good way.
The room joins in on the puzzled reactions
as this girl wakes up and we find out
her name is Kishimoto.
But just then, a sinister anthem
begins to roar from within the black sphere,
captivating everyone in the room.
Digital text.
Then begins to appear on the sphere
that reads to everyone in this room
that their old lives are gone
and that this strange black orb
will decide how to use their new lives
and then it begins to display
a horrifying image of a strange beast
that this fear wants them to go kill right
before its interior pops open, displaying
an array of high tech weaponry
along with a strange sleeping
man inside the sphere itself
and inside, along with all of this case's
containing suits
with all of their names on it.
And so the group with more questions
than answers begins suiting up.
And Kei notices that this one kid
creepy face, is seemingly already suited up
and seems way more calm
than the rest of the group here.
But he doesn't have time to dwell on it
because this guy starts
fizzling out of existence
and the rest of the gang begins
freaking out one by one following this guy's
lead as they all disappear from existence.
Right into this random alley.
However, this creepy haired kid
finally spills the beans
and tells everyone that they all got here
through hypnosis
and that he's the son of the producer of this
holographic TV show, that they're all in
saying that if they complete the mission,
they'll all win ¥100 million as a reward.
But something is off.
And Kei doesn't trust him for one second.
Okay?
Something isn't right here.
There's no way that this creepy faced kid
what he's saying is true, because up
until now, the only VR type technology
out there for public
use has been through holographic capabilities
represented through modern air.
What we saw with Princess
Leia as a holographic back in Star Wars
is largely
something
out of the realm of modern science still,
which means there's no way that humans
can produce the perception of holograms
in standard non modified atmospheric air
without the presence of some type of headset.
Even the famous hologram of Tupac Shakur on
the stage was in fact not a hologram,
but was actually a 2D image projected
onto an angled piece of glass, which was then
projected onto a transparent screen
along with the help of a projector.
The point is that we're out in the open
and we ain't wearing no Google glasses,
which means there's
no possible way that this creepy faced kid.
What he's saying is in fact true.
But let's say that it was.
Then that means whoever put us
in this virtual reality
clearly has the technological
and financial capabilities
to put us in a virtual world
where we cannot trust our own senses.
And that is terrifying.
The one thing that we can take away
from all of this is Creepy Face Kid himself,
because when we arrived into that room,
he was the only one
who was already suited up and the only one
who had any explanation at all
as to what was going on.
And he's the only one who exhibited
the confidence to spew that lie.
If this really was a competitive match
with ¥100 million on the line,
then why would he give away
the objective willy nilly?
Why would he say anything at all?
Saying nothing would have given him
a better shot at winning the money, right.
Something is going on with Creepy Face Kid
because he seems to know
something that we don't,
which is why I would keep a close eye on him
and his actions, because us looking out
for him actually means that we are looking
after ourselves in the process.
The group of lost players then noticed
something strange in the distance, watching
them, something green and not quite human,
and also holding a green onion.
Creepy Face Kid then points out that
that little green abomination is the target
and that whoever catches it within 20 minutes
wanes, causing the entire group of money
hungry players to hunt down their target.
The group catches up to this strange green
alien
and it begins to offer its green
onion to the group.
But they don't give two shits
about no green onions
as they like their lips in anticipation
while they prepare to kill this creature.
But suddenly this sneaky green little bastard
slips away right over the fence as he
jumps over this fence like a superhuman,
forcing the gang to continue the chase,
following him down the street right
past our unbothered domain heroes
and right into this dingy garage,
the group of players have finally managed
to corner this green onion,
knowing that their actions
within the next few minutes
will change their lives
and their fate forever.
The green onion head of an alien
begs to be spared
as it offers its green onions again
as a token of friendship.
But it's no use.
These players want blood,
and they ready their Arcadia
looking weaponry with no idea how it works.
And this dude takes a shot and nothing.
The gang wonders if their weapons are broken,
but then suddenly an explosion
erupts from within the green alien
as his entire arm is blasted off of his body,
angering this little green alien
and making it dangerously handsy
with our players,
causing the group to get pissed off
as this time they all fire simultaneously
at this monster, causing his body
to savagely get blasted apart as its guts
spray all over the entire room.
And this guy, this sicko, he likes
what he sees and fires another shot
before Cotto angrily tries to stop him.
But suddenly their problems
get about seven feet bigger
because right behind them is another alien.
And this one looks like the green onions
older brother, and he looks past the money
hungry gang of idiots standing in front
of it, paralyzed as hell and this terrifying
monster towers over our unlucky players
as they prepare to battle or die.
But this Yakuza
wannabe is too much of a stud to give a shit
and decides to confront this beast head on.
Suddenly he hears a swift
crack erupt from below him
and he looks down to his leg in sheer horror
shock quickly sets in for our gangster
stud as he collapses in front of this monster
light.
As the beast grabs
his skull and lifts him up into the air,
the group begins to freak out
right as they blast off a couple of rounds
at this horrifying monster.
But they can't land a single shot
as this creature uses Yakuza stud
as a meat shield, blocking all of the shots
with terrifying ease.
Okay, this is terrifying, but in all
fairness, they should have seen the signs.
If we follow the fact that these matches
categorize themselves as games
then that means that these death games
would likely follow
some semblance of game structure,
such as the inclusion of boss battles
found within almost all types of games
in various genres.
With the structure of boss battles usually
being found at the end of each sector,
just as when the intensity
within the game rises to its peak,
followed by the defeat of the boss,
at which the intensity
will usually die down for a bit
after hunting the little green onion alien.
It was clearly an easy enemy to defeat,
and it's no wonder that the first enemy
for the first game for our players
was the easiest one,
meaning that the gang could have stopped to
maybe
think about this for a minute,
that this was a game.
How many enemies would they have to hunt
before the difficulty went up,
and how many enemies would they have to hunt
within the first game before?
Harder, more terrifying enemies show up.
This is why I would have stopped
and maybe would have tried to capture
the little green onion
and then figure out our next
step,
and I would have been as hasty as they were.
And from the looks of his cute little sweet,
weird face, this little green onion baby
was clearly a child,
which means that it's safe
to say that what we're up against
now would be the parent,
or at least really pissed off older
relative of our now deceased onion friend.
Because what the gang is up against
now is a more mature green onion alien.
And from what we have just witnessed,
this creature has the ability to produce
razor sharp
claws from his hands that can obviously maim
and kill people right here on the spot.
And this creature's offensive abilities
means that we're better off
fighting him in an open space and not within
an enclosed area such as this one.
This thing is currently carrying
one of the other players
and using him as a freaking meat
shield of sorts. And that's awesome.
Which means that we have no way
of stopping him right here.
So if I'm K, I'd simply use a glasses guy
in front of me as my own share of meat
and push him right at this angry green
onion creature as a distraction
before running behind him
and out of the garage entirely.
Once out in the open
will have a better shot of killing him
without having
to be so ridiculously close to his claws.
And besides, this guy has shown himself
to be a rather physically weak individual.
So I say for the greater good, he should do
the noble cause of sacrificing himself
for us. Right?
His death is the best
bet in getting out of here alive.
The Yakuza wannabe guy suddenly explodes
sending his tender organs everywhere.
This alien monster is out for blood, and
everyone here is about to die a brutal death
and they know it elsewhere.
K walks nearby
as he hears the screams of petrified victims,
causing him to check out the same garage
as our alien friend.
Just as a blood covered Kato stands
there, practically shedding bricks.
Corpses of some of the players encircle
this green demon
as it slowly pushes them out into the alley,
ready to spill more blood.
But then in comes Kishimoto
flying wild and taking shots, whipping
this horrifying monster
right into the concrete slab and nearby.
But she ain't prepared for shit
has her corner.
I notices
the corpse filled garage in front of her
along with a paralyzed and stricken Kato.
Just then this green beast rises back
up, taking sudden swings at Kishimoto and K
making Kishimoto realize that her suit
protected her and making Kei realize
that the suit is the key to surviving quips
the green monster on the head to no effect
pissing off our alien friend who roars
just as he prepares to die himself.
Though suddenly the snapping and whipping
of an alien round pierces through the air
and ties up our alien friend right
as creepy face guy fizzles into existence
thanks to his invisibility suit.
I want one.
Looks like that little shit was hiding
and watching the whole time.
Creepy face
kid then offers for K to kill
this captured monster,
but he's too much of a goody two shoes
to take the shot and chokes, forcing creepy
face kid to handle it himself
and he shoots this beast
right in front of them,
causing the game to suddenly end
and the group appears back in the same room
as before and their creepy face kid divulges
the name of the mysterious Black
Sphere Guards just then this glasses
guy comes back to join
the group, showing us that
no matter how far on the brink of death
someone is,
if they survive the round, they'll come back
fully healed after the game ends.
Gantz then relays
score points for everybody on the screen
as Kei demands to know what is going on,
forcing creepy face kid to reveal
that they are here to stop an alien invasion
from attacking Earth and that.
Except for him,
this is the first time that he's
seen anyone survive more than a single round
within Gantz and this news freaks
K out who picks up his pistol and directs
it right a creepy kid's sweet face before K
suddenly is teleported back to his room
almost as if it were a dream.
Holy crap, this is insane.
But here's the thing.
We don't know if what just happened was real
because like I said, technology
up until this point that we know of
has not developed tech with the capabilities
to make everything around us
into a perfect realist.
Like Star Trek holodeck.
And to add to that, we just woke up
in our bed with no memory of how we got here.
Nor do we remember how we got to
that empty room either.
So really, we're at a loss for words
and throw in aliens into the mix,
which means there's a pretty good chance
that whatever happened
was just a terrifying dream.
But here's the thing.
This wasn't any old dream
because we saw a long lost friend from school
who we haven't seen in years,
which is why, to be safe,
I would follow up on all possible leads
just on the off chance
that whatever happened, it really did happen
because how many times
have we heard of alien encounters in the news
since this stuff started being reported
back in the sixties?
A lot,
which means statistically it's not crazy
to think
that we could be one of the few people
who has just experienced an alien encounter.
Now, if this is the case,
then our only chance of finding out
what's going on
will be making sure our timeline
within the last 24 hours
matches that of the people within the game
if we can find them in real life.
Because if we can find
even one of our team mates,
this will clear up everything in minutes
because they'll either think we're nuts
or will probably give us a hug
and be glad that someone else
actually believes their crazy
alien hunting story.
In this instance,
we have our long lost friend Kato,
who mentions that they went
to the same school together.
So in this case, I would start there, begin
by finding him
either through the school directory
or by going online and using social media
to identify the locations of his hangouts.
And all of this will give us a better shot
at finding him before the next game starts.
If we start looking right
now, K wakes up confused as all
hell not knowing
what in the world just happened,
but he knows someone who might have
some answers.
His old buddy
Kato, forcing K to comb through the Japanese
phone books looking for his long lost friend
and his address.
Finding the winning ticket.
K rushes out, hoping that
whatever is going on has ended for good.
K later reaches Kato's old address
but realizes that nothing is there.
Then again, Kato's address is from ten years
ago, making K to be even more stumped
and lost for answers than ever,
forcing him to head back home.
An idiotic shame.
But on the way there he passes
by an alley and notices something horrifying.
It's the same alley from last night
and the same dingy garage from before,
except its bloodstained
walls are nowhere to be seen,
which means that whatever happened last night
could have been real.
But Kei's crusher shit is real
as he bumps into a right.
Then in there and he spots her Gantt suit
showing from her bag along with Kato's jacket
that she wore back in dance,
making it even harder
to ignore that what happened
last night was real,
but with no blood stained walls
and no Kato, the gang disappointed.
Lee calls it a day, and Kei prepares
to walk a Kishimoto home like a gentleman.
Right.
But Kishimoto
then asks the most horrifying thing ever,
most horrifyingly awesome thing ever.
That is, as she asks Kei if she can stay
with him tonight as she has no place to live
thanks to an angry ex-boyfriend
who just kicked her out making his loss.
Kei's gain as he tries to play it cool
and the duo heads back to his apartment
where some very expected graded action
happens as a nothing happens as in Kishimoto
steels K's bed before the tired and confused
duo pass out in awkward silence.
Bummer.
But on the other side of town, Carter
wakes up from a nightmare
just before telling his little brother
to head back to bed,
not realizing that whatever happened to him
and the others is about to happen again
because just then half of his face
begins disappearing
just as before, with his body
fizzling back out and right
back into the same room as everyone else,
right into the room with gas
as K Kato
and Kishimoto look on in
sheer terror at each other
and all of the newcomers in the room,
including a kid, his grandma glasses guy,
and some other random people
looking just as confused
as Kei and Kato were when they first died,
along with creepy face kid in the background,
looking just as predatory as ever. Okay.
This confirms the fact that this is
in fact happening, folks,
and that this is not a dream,
which means we are screwed.
And judging from the last time,
we have less than 4 minutes
until we get teleported
into the next horrifying death game.
But this time we're not the confused ones.
Because we have this dude,
a grandma, her kid.
I mean, we have some real meat
shield options, but let's be honest.
Creepy kid won't tell us. And he's really
the only one from the first game.
Who knows what's going on?
Which means for now, he's on the same side
as us.
And the new people in this room
don't look too smart either, suckers.
So I would pull a page
right out of this bastard's book,
and tell the rest of the players
that we're in a holographic game
funded by neuroscientists
to test out the concept of fear
using high tech implanted chips
and that whatever we're about to see within
the game isn't real.
Whatever pain we experience isn't real,
however real it might feel.
Remember,
I don't think these people are that smart.
So this flat out lie,
I think should be just enough to do its job.
The fact is, is that we can use
these people's gullibility.
I'm looking at this grandma to our advantage
and make them act as our unofficial meat
shills that I talked about. Earlier.
Once the game begins,
I'd also begin
to keep these people distracted and keep
our guard suits tucked inside our briefcases
until the game begins.
This way, when we put our suits on the other,
people won't have a suit to worry about
since they won't have one, because we need
these noobs powerless and dependent on us,
because the last thing we need for
them is to get pissed off at us and start
taking superhuman
potshots at us in their Gantt suits.
Because screw that idea.
I don't like it. Creepy face, kid.
Then Sadistically says that
no matter where they are in the world,
Gantz will always find them
and bring them back to play more death games.
The gang looks in sheer horror.
One by one, they begin to disappear,
and Kei and Kato quickly
try to arm the rest of the group
while this grandma and kid
get separated upon arrival into this death
arena and end up bumping into this horrifying
robotic alien.
And it walks right up to these innocent folks
and opens its mouth, revealing a bright
light from within as it prepares
to murder them right here and now.
All the while, this innocent child and sweet
old lady look on in sheer hopelessness.
Nearby, Kei finally appears into the arena
parking lot, but comes face to face
with something straight out of a horror film.
It's the grandma had boy or their corpses
who lay there like abandoned rag dolls
dead on the street. It's horrifying.
Just then,
he sees the infamous murder creature standing
opposite of him, ready
for a showdown to the death.
Standing opposite of Kei is his next target,
the Tanaka alien.
Okay.
I guess they made this monster different
than the one in the anime, which we also did
a video on which you can check out up
in the corner here.
But this robot in the anime is actually
a suit that houses the most insane thing
ever inside a bird, as in an actual alien
bird known as the Tanaka Alien.
A race of freakishly huge birds
that use that suit in front of us
right here as some sort of a space suit to be
able to breathe inside Earth's atmosphere.
Like, no joke.
There's an actual bird inside of that robot
people. I'm not kidding.
And while this dude looks a little different
than in the anime, I'm willing to bet
that his suit works pretty much the same way.
And this type of info is invaluable to us
because this means that without their suit,
they're screwed
However, their main attack is a high pitched
supersonic blast emitted from their mouth
that can cause hemorrhaging from the eyes
and ears, as in serious bleeding.
And while we do have firearms,
they likely wouldn't do so well at long range
due to this alien creature's agility
and ability to dodge attacks at high speeds.
This means that our best bet
would be to use the team that we have
and actually use them,
and not for just meat shields,
darn it, in order to actually go up
against these creature from different angles.
If I'm Keie, I would advise all members
to go with this beast from all angles
simultaneously
while he tries to take us all down.
And in doing so,
we'll be able to keep it distracted
until one of us eventually closes
the gap and gets right in its face.
Because remember,
without their suit, the alien from within
can't last very long in our environment.
And it will then die shortly thereafter.
This means using our suits
heightened abilities,
we could super humanly squeeze the shit
right out of it until the suit gets damaged
enough to the point where the creature
will have to exit the suit of its own.
Sheer will.
Because let's be honest, who would want
to stay inside a crushed astronaut suit?
Not me.
So let us use that to our advantage.
K like a freaking area just stands
there and fires a shot at the Tanaka Alien
while pretty much receiving this aliens
blast head on.
Suddenly the Tanaka
alien's face shakes at a frightening speed
and then launches a blast into nothing
until it connects with creepy face kid
in the distance.
That Tanaka alien knew where he was
despite him being invisible.
That Tanaka alien rises fast into the air
and dove bombs headfirst into Creepy Face
Kid, plunging him down into the basement
parking lot
and he proceeded to beat the shit out of him
while the rest of the gang fizzles
into existence.
Bud Carter was a stud, cut above the rest
and jumps down onto the Tanaka alien
right before it kills Creepy Face Kid
and Kato squeezes the life out of the alien,
getting some help from his super suit,
causing this creature
to go down for the count.
K rushes over to Creepy Face Kid
as his shattered voice
mutters for K to save him
when he eventually gets 100 points.
But Kei has no clue as to
what the hell he's talking about.
As creepy face Kid finally kicks the bucket.
Suddenly, however, the Tanaka alien blasts up
with more gusto than a bowl on Red Bull,
knocking Kato back as he tries to take
potshots at Kishimoto, Kato quickly swings
back around to protect her and gets the shit
kicked out of him instead, with Kato himself
getting forced, mouth-To-Mouth
and is about to have his head blasted off
right before Kishimoto knocks
this alien space off with some last minute
sultry moves but this creature is too damn
powerful and knocks everyone back.
Just as Kei learns how to use his super suit
and gives this alien a taste
of his own medicine, beating the alien down
into a car as the two intimately
duke it out until the alien grabs case face
and is about to blast his face off.
When Kei suddenly grabs his gun
from the car floor
and shoves his gun into the aliens mouth
and fires, causing a sudden explosion to
erupt from the car itself, killing the alien
and winning the game as the gang and Kei,
nearly on the brink of death, appear
back in front of Gant's
good as new,
but he doesn't have time to play around
and demands to know what happens
when someone gets 100 points.
And that's when Gantz shows him
the 100 point menu showing two options
for players to choose from that list
should they ever reach that many points.
Option one Gain your freedom option
to bring someone who died from within against
came back to life just as everyone
then teleports back to their old lives.
However, this time Kei, already
wearing his suit, has some ideas
and begins training with a suit
in the real world,
vowing to get stronger for the next time
when the next game inevitably summons him
back.
Elsewhere, a Kato Chak of an apartment
he sees on the news that the explosion
that happened last night in dance was real,
and he quickly realizes
that the world is going to shit
that is up to him and gets to stop them.
And our three heroes ready themselves
mentally for the next game.
And sure enough,
the next game arrives and summons them
accordingly, this time with fresh meat.
As our veteran trio
head into the game with their wits about them
and Gantz gives them their next target,
the game gets teleported
to this place, a sinister looking museum,
just as this new pops off on one statue
causing the one right next to it
to come to life.
Okay. This is insanely horrifying
for this encounter.
We lack any prior knowledge on
what the hell this thing is.
But unlike the Tanaka Alien
or the Green Onion Alien,
this thing seems to lack the capabilities
to perform any longer range attacks on us,
whether that be in the form of energy blasts
or retractable claws like our good old green
onion friend here,
which means we may have a chance.
And in this case,
I would continue to stay out in the open
so we don't get trapped
in the corner of the wall
where this monster's brute force strength
would surely have an upper hand on us.
Keeping a distance
will be key for us to have the upper hand.
From the looks of things,
at least one of them
has something more
than the standard Gantz x gun,
which is a small handgun sized weapon
that does better at close range encounters.
This guy.
Yeah, this one is carrying an x shotgun
which is similar to the x gun.
In almost every way
except when it comes to long distance.
It has a higher accuracy
that can be fired in the hands of someone
proficient from over one kilometer away.
This is why we need to get this guy out
from under this creature's legs literally
and get him to a safe distance
from which he'll be able to take a shot
more effectively.
Because a creature of this size
makes me suspect
that a simple shot from the X gun
won't do much.
If I was care,
Kato, I'd snag the X gun shotgun for myself
and all of the rest of my comrades to begin
distracting this beast
with additional suppressing
fire to keep him at bay while we ready up
our shot from a safer distance.
as everyone freaks the hell out and scurries
like rats desperate to survive.
Just one more day with this monk
and this chick heading inside, leaving Kei
pretty much all by himself
against this ugly beast, right?
As this monster tries taking shots at anyone
he can get his hands on.
And it's about to stomp on this one dude
until his whole lake explodes,
thanks to some good
ol alien rounds provided by Kato.
Just as Kei readies his bad ass pistol,
now turns rifle right at this abomination,
causing it to explode right here and now.
But Kishimoto doesn't
have time to celebrate as she
then watches Kaki Kei declare to Kato that
he's pretty much the bigger chad
and can handle everything
that Gantz throws at him.
But something is not right.
Because they haven't teleported
back to Gantz yet,
which means this death game isn't over,
not by a long shot.
And they're so right because what awaits
them is truly more horrifying.
Than they could ever imagine.
And it will cost them everyone back in sight.
This scared monk hides
from the action outside and thinks he's safe,
but no one is safe.
And Gantz just as he notices something
strange from across this statute filled room.
But he just thinks he's hallucinating
as he continues to pray to his gods,
not realizing
that he's about to face a god right now.
He then opens his eyes again and notices
the most horrifying thing
standing right in front of him.
The true enemy of Gantz, this bronzed beast
and right outside those horrifying door
stands, this girl as she tries to see
from inside if the horrors outside are over.
And she too gets the bright idea
to go inside of that treacherous room
closing the doors on what might as well
be her valuable life back outside.
Can Kato stand there as they try
to figure out what the hell is going on?
Just as they
suddenly hear the opening of the museum door
revealing a battle torn player
as she collapses in front of them,
K then realizes that their horror show
isn't over as he and the gang cautiously comb
through the insides
of this sinister atrium, aiming their sights
on the sight of their final battleground,
of which they slowly enter,
only to see the horrifying corpse of the monk
from earlier or what's left of him
causing their fight or flight instincts
to go off from within their gut.
Knowing what
we know that they're screwed, right?
As Kato realizes what he sees a thousand
armed Buddha bringing Keie to his knees
and disarming him in an instant.
Okay, this is a little crazy
and kind of horrifying at the same time,
especially when we consider that
unlike the rest of the aliens
that we thought so far,
we don't know anything about this creature
except for whatever
few visual similarities that it shares
with the actual thousand armed oddity
in real life. Known in Himalayan Buddhism.
But that's pretty much
where the similarities end, folks,
and with no other information given to us
by Gantz or kind of at a huge disadvantage.
However, Gantz is no idiot, presumably,
and so we should trust that the weapons it's
provided for us should work
if we can actually land a shot,
because from what we've seen, this
alien has superhuman speed
and is lethal at close distances,
which doesn't take a genius to figure out.
I mean, have you seen how many arms
it's got at this point?
What we can use is the power of teamwork
or more specifically teamwork
that proceeds into backstabbing,
because in reality
it's every man for himself.
And so if I was king, I would lie to Kato
and tell him to distract this alien
with his sword at close range
along with Kishimoto, while I try and line up
to take a shot from a distance.
Now, what's brilliant about this
and different from before
is that with Kato
fighting alongside with Kishimoto, from what
we know of how Kishimoto feels for Kato,
judging from her love stares
throughout the entire movie,
this would make her a lot more susceptible
to making sure
that she protects Kato at all costs.
And if he gets cut,
which he probably will, let's be honest.
And that'll make Kishimoto
all the more inclined to go crazy and fight
this alien even harder.
That is the power of love, my friends.
And this is what will make her
the perfect distraction to keep this alien
busy while we take it out from a distance.
And if they die at the end,
at least we live this thousand arms,
God then lays down attrition
with a bombardment of sword upon a disarmed K
as a cross to safety,
but not without some serious scratches,
leaving him
crippled enough to tag team in Kato.
But not before our sweet bro
session happens between the two,
helping to fuel the rage within Kato
and have him rise
back up to tackle this monster
head on, entering a now empty room with the
nothing but some clues left behind
as to where this horrifying monster could be.
Suddenly it pops up from behind him,
slashing the glass in front of K
and almost taking an eye out in the process.
And now the two stand ready to duel mano
a mano.
The 1000 armed Buddha that lays out a code
whisper of anger filled words
saying they killed its friends
and that it will have revenge upon
all of them sending a shiver up and down
Kato's arm because he knows what he's in for.
Just then,
a loud explosion erupts in front of K
as the monster disappears, right as Kishimoto
stands with her smoking gun, yelling
for Kei to run just as she gets knocked down
and disarmed by the monster.
The Baron Beast approaches her menacingly.
But that's when Kato charges up
with his sword,
like Kyoto, with his overpowered dual blades,
sending in precision strikes like a surgeon
until he gets pummeled back hard.
Right then the bronze monster charges
up to finish the job,
forcing Kishimoto to sacrifice herself
for Kato and her limp corpse falls down
to the floor, causing a feeble Kato
to hold her closely and do the obligatory
attempted love before dying, seen
just as she kicked the bucket in his arms.
But this cutesy wannabe
couple is enough to fuel Kato
with enough juice, but to overcome his pain.
And he charges back in to fight this demon
a final time and a final time.
It proves to be for him, just as he gets
stabbed right in front of a helpless K,
throwing his corpse
in front of his best friend,
making this the last straw for K,
the feeble
K thing grabs his fallen comrade sword
and attacks this creature for a final time.
But it's hopeless as it sends K back yet
again, making him take a different approach
like with this gun,
making him jump in the air
as the Buddha swords grace his skin
and Superman jumps over this thing and G.I.
Joe rolls right over onto his weapon
as he rolls in arms himself with his sights
set on this thousand armed demon it's done
and Kei fires off around,
but this thing deflects it,
resulting in an explosion,
and this creature reveals
a trump card up its sleeve.
This many statue of itself as this Buddha
demon drops it right down past K
as he lays
witness to what horrifyingly happens next,
this little statue begins to twitch
as its little form begins to expand
into something straight
out of a horror movie, forcing
K to get some distance from it.
But it's no use.
The other players outside
looking all in terror as this monster
practically ascends from hell for a second
now much tinier K to scurry back a smidge
as he prepares for the final showdown.
Okay, talk about our worst nightmare
and add to that
our worst enemy is now
a billion times larger.
And at this point we have little option
because we clearly can't outrun this thing.
But our best
bet at this point would be against
say it with when our folks teamwork
makes the dream work
time is ticking
and a ton of our teammates are dead.
But we do have a few meet shields.
I mean, friends left alive,
as we can clearly see.
So I would order these two players
to run within the museum itself
and make this Godzilla alien,
chase them throughout the entire structure,
destroying everything
and its site as it tries to kill them.
Then while it does this,
if I'm Okay, I would try to get up close
and personal to this
giant alien's head for a closer shot at it
because I don't see any shotgun
anywhere any more,
which means
all we got left is our little gun,
and we risk that alien
blocking our shots with its hands
if we try and fire it
from too far of a distance.
This is why we need to get in close
this gigantic statue.
Then Hulk smashes Kei, causing him to run
for his life like a squirrel to his nut.
And he sees in the distance
Kato he's alive, and they bro telepathy one
another to come up with a last minute plan.
Having K here run up into the Buddhist fist
as Kato fires his gun, causing K to slip out
and continue running forward up
this monster's
body, getting headbutted back down and coming
face to face with this horrifying creature.
Just then,
k Superman jumps right into the monster's
mouth before he blasts this beast incites
and it explodes everywhere.
Right then k comes out of the storm
like a stud and sees his best friend
right before he to kick the bucket, causing k
to suddenly appear back in the room
with gas and the rest of the survivors
with k then realizing that his best friend
isn't back yet and his score
tally tops off at 13, just as gas reveals
that his fallen bro is trapped within cans.
But you don't simply stop being a bro.
And so with 87 more points to go, K
then vows to fight as many alien bastards
as it'll take to rescue his best bro.
And maybe Kishi Moto one day.
Hey guys,
thank you so much for watching our video.
Don't forget to like subscribe.
Let us know what you like
and what you didn't like.
And also don't forget to check out our
How to Be playlist and our social media.